Державна зрада і сприяння тероризму.
Таке закидають експрезиденту Петру Порошенку.
Це перехід червоних ліній. Це вже не жарти, жарти закінчилися.
Жарти закінчилися 17 грудня.
Тоді слідчі Державного бюро розслідувань вирішили вручити колишньому президенту повістку на допит.
Але не вдалося.
Візьміть повістку, будь ласка. - Поехали, ** твою мать!
Порошенко нібито поспішав до Стамбула, на зустріч із Вселенським патріархом.
Потім - у Польщу. Тим часом йому буквально "у хвіртку" запхали підозру у держзраді.
Адвокати експрезидента вважають таке "вручення" документа незаконним.
Слідчі це заперечують і чекають Порошенка на допит.
Той же має намір повернутися в Україну вже після свят.
Мені передають вітання з Офісу президента, що вони з розумінням поставляться до того, якби я залишився в Європі.
Я хочу наголосити, що я не надам їм такого подарунку і повернуся в Україну в першій половині січня,
але за своїм графіком, а не за графіком потужного сценариста відосиків пана Зеленського.
У чому ж, власне, суть підозри?
Порошенко в 2014 році нібито зірвав поставки вугілля з Південної Африки й організував його закупки в ОРДЛО.
Як наслідок - збагатив бойовиків на понад 200 мільйонів гривень.
Усе це - за змовою з Віктором Медведчуком і за вказівкою з Кремля.
…поставив Україну в енергетичну залежність від представників РФ та вказаних псевдореспублік…
І сам Петро Порошенко, і його захисники звинувачення відкидають.
Справу називають політичною і сфабрикованою.
Цього не було і не могло бути.
Дивіться, навіщо так складно було?
Якби існував умисел, якби змова існувала, ну віддали б готівку, яка в банківських сховищах була,
ну віддали б готівку, яка в банках в Криму була, якщо треба було.
Навіщо було городити таку складну історію з вугіллям?
А в тому і була проблема, що без цього вугілля в Україні тоді була загроза колапсу.
Підозру адвокати вважають юридично нікчемною.
У тексті трапляються помилки: наприклад, рік вказаний нинішній, а не 2014.
А головне, кажуть, доказів бракує.
Коли, де і як відбувалася змова Порошенка з Медведчуком, слідчі не встановили.
Так само і ще кілька важливих обставин у провадженні.
Слідчі ж переконують, що доказів злочинної змови вистачає.
Насамперед ідеться про десятки годин записів нібито розмов Медведчука
про вугільні контракти з представниками Кремля.
У записах, які оприлюднювала СБУ, згадувався й Порошенко.
Ну, значить, дивись, я зустрічався і в суботу, і в неділю, і вчора, ну, з нашим… головним.
Ну, а з вугіллям ніби все нормально сприйнято.
Якщо суд визнає експрезидента винним у змові й сприянні терористам, йому загрожує від 12 до 15 років за ґратами.
Утім, захисники Порошенка припускають, що до суду справа не дійде.
Проти п'ятого президента за останні кілька років відкривали вже десятки кримінальних проваджень.
До суду потрапило поки лише одне з них - про призначення Порошенком нібито з "власних інтересів"
Сергія Семочка на посаду голови служби зовнішньої розвідки.
Утім, влітку 2020-го суд так і не обрав запобіжний захід Порошенку й справа зійшла нанівець.
Обвинувачення на адресу колишнього глави держави вже тоді викликали занепокоєння на Заході,
адже скидалися на політичне переслідування.
Так само сприймають європейські експерти й нинішню ситуацію.
На мою думку, у будь-якого українського політика можна знайти щось, щоб відкрити провадження.
Можу собі уявити, що у деяких випадках це обґрунтовано.
Але нині очевидно, що президенту Зеленському йдеться не про притягнення Порошенка до відповідальності
за принципом верховенства права та не про розслідування певних речей,
а про намагання відволікти від власних слабкостей.
Це радше політично вмотивоване переслідування, а не правове.
Справи з політичним присмаком можуть суттєво вплинути на ставлення західних держав до Києва,
певен співробітник аналітичного центру Atlantic Council Пітер Дікінсон.
Один з факторів, які завжди слугують на користь Україні - це те,
що вона вважається демократичною державою, вартою політичних і геополітичних інвестицій.
Якщо адміністрація Зеленського вдаватиметься до, так би мовити, політичного правосуддя,
переслідуватиме політичних опонентів, це нашкодить демократичній репутації України.
Західні держави можуть втратити мотивацію підтримувати Україну.
Не цілком, звичайно, але можуть менш активно це робити.
Крім того, західні експерти відзначають: нову "справу Порошенка" почали дуже невчасно.
Зараз Україна - одна з найважливіших тем у світі.
Адже їй загрожує потужний наступ Росії, говорять навіть про можливу війну, якої в Європі не бачили з часів Гітлера і Сталіна.
Але замість того, аби об'єднати Україну на тлі такої небезпеки,
влада країни вирішує, що саме час для політичної "вендети".
Це взагалі недоречно. І це свідчить про певну безвідповідальність президента Зеленського.
Йому важливіший він сам, а не країна.
І те, що він, так би мовити, розкручує це в такій складній ситуації - це також недбалість.
За обвинуваченнями проти експрезидента пильно стежать у Вашингтоні й Лондоні.
Посольства США і Великобританії закликали Україну до дотримання принципу верховенства права
й до неупередженого розслідування.